this episode of 30 people one question
is a little different for this week's
episode I thought it would be fun to ask
30 strangers to help me film the music
video for one of my favorite songs of
all time
now the actual music video is going to
be premiering on my channel next week
Tuesday the 27th but if you also want to
watch some behind the scenes footage
from the day of filming the music video
then keep watching this episode my cards
are specially customized for today
instead of saying 30 people one question
this is 30 people one music video
introduce yourself I'm she's obsessed
with acai bowls I'm gonna get her one at
the end of this day because she's
helping me out just get into my car you
know I Drive a Tesla wanna tell them how
I Drive all my neighbors just heard me
pretending like you have a Tesla and
they probably look at me getting it into
Volkswagen
[Music]
[Music]
all right well no what are we doing to
you we are filming there any people once
out with me 30 people on music video but
I'm not tying that one music what song
it is
[Music]
of all time like I don't like favorite
Sun fish anyone's home right I have to
do I sing in the shower thought you knew
the song when I built keep hyping it up
so they could and then you put her whole
elbow on iphone I'm sure every single
person know this is named for her first
name don't comment below we made it we
found a parking spot and we're here and
we're about to get started law and tell
me your predictions for today I know
Emily vanilla forest
everyone only Lawrence's maybe not I'm
really likes her but she's Hornish like
preaching so hard about this girl cool
I'm a song so I'm gonna hand the subject
the phone and I'm gonna play the song
and it could either live seeing it or
actually seeing it but it doesn't it
won't really matter either way because
I'm gonna put the actual song over the
video you won't really hear what's
happening on actual footage you feel me
yes
[Music]
yo Moses and I'll tell you to play the
music better if you do sing it sing it
like you're going all at him give me a
paper
I wanna spin move while you're walking
your hands in it what is he singing and
then we each come in and stuff but then
like when it comes to all of us
[Music]
ok let's do it you're gonna be like into
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up guys me and Lana here we're
done filming it was a pretty successful
day of filming gonna my favorite time
filming it was your favorite day filming
with me I don't number anymore why was
it your favorite day of filming why was
the height and the people more in it
like exactly my god we got a lot of
rejections but the people who were in it
made the day like so fun yeah like
you'll see the behind the scenes these
people has encouraged yeah they had some
courage and I was gonna do the whole
song but I realized that after 2 hours
of filming I only had one fourth of the
song done and follow me that quality is
better than quantity so I focused on
making that quarter really good instead
of making the whole song okay and those
people are like very quality
what else I am ready for nothing evil
yeah I get I'm gonna die alone and I'll
save up for helping me today thanks
again
[Music]
is it good